people ask me all the time I talk about
finding or attracting your ideal partner
really and that really stems from from
you and you developing your ideal self
people really want that sort of cheat
sheet of like what are the things that
you look for to find that ideal partner
and first of all it's not just one
person but there's probably a limited
supply of ideal matches for you in the
universe not everyone is an ideal
partner not 50% of people are gonna be
an ideal partner so yes it's gonna be a
smaller percentage and so you have to
learn what to look for and it's based on
you developing yourself according to
your personality what fits best for you
the lifestyle that you choose to lead
your values belief systems and generally
speaking that fluctuates over your life
span but usually you know in your 30s
maybe late twenties you'll sort of
solidify a lot of that we actually
didn't wear work in the self-development
part then we would probably do but a
much better job of attracting the right
type of people to us
I am joined by dr. Taylor Burroughs
today miss burrows welcome to the show
thank you thank you for having me I'm
excited I'm very excited to have you one
as well I'm right in thinking that
you've got essentially a PhD in
relationships yeah you could say that
it's a PhD in marriage couples and
Family Therapy so that almost covers
them all that's it you're a doctor of
relationships yeah and you know I like
to include the relationship with oneself
as well so that's included in there too
fantastic how is your relationship with
yourself today it's going very well I
did a really good workout I'm staying at
this beautiful condo and I just had a
lovely afternoon and then I talked it up
with like a full home-cooked meal and
then did like an evening stroll on South
Beach which I bumped into a lot of
characters and it was lots of fun so I'm
doing well did you take yourself out for
a date yeah basically that sounds like
the ultimate date night but just with
yourself that's actually my plan evening
I like to do that quite often actually
so that's the norm in my world amazing
so we're just going to riff on
relationships today I guess we've had a
lot of interesting characters on
recently we did a full series of four
episode series on our advice on
relationships and I've recently had
Caleb Jones on who's a non-monogamy
advocate talking about his sort of views
I guess to start off what does 14 years
of clinical mental health and marriage
and family counseling look like when you
come out the other side of that what
what are the sort of experiences that
you have in that well it evolved in
stages basically you know like when
you're a green intern they say you know
you have a supervisor you're kind of
like half licensed so you're more of a
student and you're kind of just learning
the ropes doing a lot of observations
and probably scared shitless actually be
in control you know
when you're you know your front and
center basically and have to kind of
cover the whole hour by yourself so you
go through this process of confidence
building really and empathy development
and so most programs the best ones will
mandate that you have to go through your
own psychotherapy and group therapy and
stuff like that so you learn what it's
like and you also process whatever may
be stuff you have from your own life
experiences because notoriously a lot of
therapists have been through a lot of
adverse events and if they haven't
sorted through their own stuff then it's
dangerous because then they can kind of
project that onto clients so that's
really important to do that yeah it is
yeah can you imagine if you had a
medical doctor that had a contagious
disease and then operated on you it's
kind of like that it's exactly what it's
like
you tell you're right you said that a
lot of counselors tend to bring in their
own problems is that a disproportionate
amount or a lot of people potentially
taking on this role or this job are they
searching that in an effort to kind of
fix themselves yeah well I won't say
that all therapists are damaged what
I'll say is that it is quite common that
when people experience trauma they
either go one or two directions right if
they don't deal with it they don't
recover properly then they can sort of
in effect go through life as if they're
damaged or handicapped emotionally right
but it also has an opposite effect so if
you do recover properly if you do access
the internal and external external
resources in order to you know heal you
can actually become an even better
person than you were before this thing
happened to you whether it was like a
singular event or whether it was just
your parents sucked or you grew up in a
poor neighborhood and witnessed some bad
things I mean it could be anything that
you experienced but the from the other
side of it interestingly enough I've had
so many clients usually like the young
teenagers that develop this desire to
want to be psychologists because of the
experience
we've had in therapy and they're like
well I want to help people or I want to
learn about what's going on with me more
so that's kind of what you see a lot
that's really interesting do you think
that perhaps some of the people that
suffer a little bit more whether it be
with personal or relationship issues are
they more susceptible to suffering
because they've got higher empathy and
then that empathy leads them towards
potentially thinking I could help other
people with that is that one of the
traits or is it something else
well sensitivity is I guess related to
empathy right so people who are highly
emotional in that in that sense would be
sensitive to extremes and positive or
negative emotions and so they can be
susceptible and if they don't learn how
to guard themselves from that and they
don't develop those coping mechanisms
that are healthy and proactive to
prevent those types of influences in
their lives then they can go through
stages where they're you know
emotionally stressed or distressed or
even dysfunctional and disordered and so
yeah a lot of times people will
gravitate to those types to sort of you
know unleash whatever is on their mind
or whatever is on their chest and some
of them just have a natural tendency of
enjoying that process and so they may
then be attracted to this profession I
understand yeah so moving on to the
nitty-gritty of marriage and couples and
family counseling and stuff like that
what were some of the trends that you
saw potentially why were people coming
in in terms of couples and and marriages
why were people coming in 14 years ago
and then you only left this year right
you stopped you stopped being a
full-time therapist this year is that
correct it was last year last year May
and yeah it was it was definitely I
wouldn't say it was a big decision
because it kind of happened gradually
and just really naturally for me as I
evolved as a therapist but also
personally too and I've talked about it
a little bit as well but what I can sort
of summarize it to say is that part of
my process and being a marriage
therapist
dealing with the pressure when I was
single of how that looked or how that
impacted my work not having had that
experience and so part of me not
consciously but it kind of pressured me
to get married
and I think that was that was in 2012 I
got married and then I ended up you know
leaving the marriage so it was a
difficult time because it's obviously
something that had carries a lot of
stigma especially if you're a marriage
therapist and why are people gonna come
to you and talk about successful
marriage you see you understand what I
was I know I'm so but it comes from both
angles and so now I've had a lot of time
since then to process what mistakes I
made what was it that I needed to apply
myself and how did I come to understand
the actual profession of marriage
therapy and so I I applied what marriage
therapy said the whole time so it kind
of aligned with all of this stuff that
I've been learning and adding to my
repertoire over the years so getting
back to your original question the
number one thing is that people are
choosing the wrong partners so that's
why I've developed my approach about
vetting in the coaching work that I do
with clients because you can't really
fix something that's fundamentally
flawed and especially if it's only one
person that maybe is motivated to make
the changes you can't do it so it's it's
really frustrating it's a waste of time
a waste of money and it just brings up
all this conflict in marital therapy
which is used as like a last case resort
anyway for the most part so I've gotten
away from all that and now I'm looking
at helping people at the dating stage
find the right partner and then do
things the right way so starting from a
point where you've got a good foundation
I mean it is anyone that's listening
surprised to hear that if you have
someone you're incompatible with your
relationships probably not going to go
well I don't think so
I think people expect that if they feel
strongly enough if they love they last
up there you know excitable and and and
whatnot that they can make it work
there's some sort of magic wand that
will erase all the problems but that's
not the case no it doesn't quite work
that way
fundamentally you've mentioned number
one one of the first thing that people
need to get right when they're looking
for a partner is that they need to find
someone that compatible with what does
that look like well people ask me all
the time I talk about finding your
attracting your ideal partner really and
that really stems from from you and you
developing your ideal self people really
want that sort of cheat sheet of like
what are the things that you look for to
find that ideal partner and first of all
it's not just one person but there's
probably a limited supply of ideal
matches for you in the universe not
everyone is an ideal partner not 50% of
people are gonna be an ideal partner so
yes it's gonna be a smaller percentage
so because I know I talk about the whole
soulmate men so there's something in
between one person for you everyone's
for you right there's gonna be like
maybe a thousand people out there or
maybe a 10,000 people who knows yeah but
it's definitely a limited supply and so
you have to learn what to look for and
it's based on you developing yourself
according to your personality what fits
best for you the lifestyle that you
choose to lead your values belief
systems and generally speaking that
fluctuates over your life span but
usually you know in your 30s maybe late
twenties you'll sort of solidify a lot
of that and so the more work that you do
rather than spending that sort of decade
of escapism and whatever you want to
call it
juvenile immature exploration will be
experimentation yeah like if we actually
didn't want work in the self-development
part then we would probably do but a
much better job of attracting the right
type of people to us yeah
so I did a podcast with Daniel sloths
who's Scottish comedian
have you heard of him mm-hmm no I don't
think so he's got a Netflix special
called jigsaw and his Twitter bio has
the stats of how many breakups and
divorces his Netflix special has caused
that it's it's a it's not a hatred of
relationships he calls it a love letter
to single people and he says that people
get pushed into relationships because
they don't feel whole without them and
saves that there's the this
meta-narrative that runs across all of
society saying that you on your own are
essentially not a whole person and that
you need to find this person that is
going to make you whole like look at any
TV show he says he talked about pitching
TV shows to networks and it's like a
comedy or something normal and they'll
say we love it but what's the love
interest and he's like well I just I
need to be a [ __ ] love interest it's
not about love but there's it is so
ubiquitous right this search for the
partner the in every even a show which
is unrelated to love there's got to be
there's got to be the love interest
right that's that's one other and it
keeps it going
and yeah he he agrees with you on what
you say you need to be able to love
yourself before you can allow someone
else to love you and before you can
really let someone in properly because
if you don't understand who you are like
how the [ __ ] just because someone else -
exactly so no I definitely agree with
that approach yeah so you mentioned
finding someone that you think is
compatible that doesn't always mean I'm
going to guess that doesn't always mean
finding someone that's the same as you
right because sometimes I opposites can
work together and stuff like that yeah
there's gonna be issues that you need
commonalities and issues that you need
polarities alright so you can you you
have to know what those things are and I
usually find that the lifestyle elements
are the ones that you need commonality
is on so if it's like you have a healthy
diet you're an active person maybe you
like to spend some time just have
developing a routine and being more
productive versus
finding any excuse to get out of the
house and and busy yourself with
socializing or whatever although
introverts and extroverts can be a very
very effective polarity it depends it
depends on a lot of factors usually the
maturity of the person because we
fluctuate through our lifespans
depending on on that characteristic but
yeah I mean the sexual polarity is
obviously the most important one when
you're talking about like chemistry and
sexual attraction desire that needs to
be really pronounced so that you you
sort of magnetize towards each other and
no matter what conflict is happening in
the relationship that can always be like
I mean people call it the glue but I
like to call it the like best
oh yeah glue glue when you're talking
about sexual polarity is a little bit
more of a sort of disgusting image isn't
it you don't have be told no one wants
to be talking about glue in that
situation is to that's too much you're a
visual person I'm guessing I can't help
it when you're using the word so when
you're talking about sexual polarity a
couple of people who are listening I
know have read David data's the way of
the superior man and in that he talks
about masculine essence and feminine
essence is that what we're talking about
with sexual polarity or is it more
nuanced than that well we can expand on
that but I it's important for and
obviously we're talking about by default
heterosexual people right I don't I
don't really talk about this the
spectrum of sexual maturation of
especially when we're talking about
masculine and female energies or
elements it applies to any orientation
but let's just stick to the stereotype
so it's easy just just to interject
there one of the things that David says
is he believes and I'd be interested to
hear your thoughts on this that even in
same-sex relationships or even in
non-monogamous relationships
he is pretty certain that the masculine
energy and the feminine energy still
manifests itself to women to men a man
and a woman or two men and two women are
however however it works there's a very
different versions
that's going on now but he's pretty
certain that the in terms of sexual
attraction you have a masculine essence
and a feminine essence and sometimes
they switch but he's pretty certain
that's the basis of sexual attraction is
is that true in your opinion I agree and
and it just gets a little bit more
complicated to talk about it when it's
and then you use the word fluid against
you more complicated but yes with same
sex that is a lot more fluid although
it's still fluid with heterosexuals
because depending on the roles that you
play and the different strengths and
weaknesses that each partner holds one
like the woman might actually lead in
the domestic area and so you know it
might be a feminine household obviously
like with if she likes you know girly
things but she's in more control so
that's more of a masculine energy so
there's lots of layers to it it gets
quite complex but in a simplified way if
you're talking about a heterosexual
female bringing the feminine energy and
it's gonna be predominantly feminine not
only feminine so each of us has both and
then the the masculine having more the
man having more the masculine energy and
so the more that a man is comfortable
and confident bringing forward and
living through that element of
masculinity and same in Reverse with the
female in her feminine then that's going
to be a literally attractive to each
other I understand so we've got choosing
someone that is compatible with you and
you mentioned lifestyle I think that's
it's so overlooked right because it
doesn't sound romantic like to talk
about the fact that I like to go to the
gym and you like to go at the cinema is
like the least romantic thing that
people believe should impact on a
relationship but the bottom line is it's
a practical consideration like if I'm
going to spend 15 hours a week in the
gym and you're gonna spend 15 hours a
week cooking or with your friends or
doing whatever it might be
those would there's just less time to
spend together there's less stuff going
on so it's like a it's like a practical
consideration right the the routines and
the compatibility in terms of what your
- yeah and you don't have to share
interests like all commonalities you can
have differences so that you have time
alone and apart which is healthy but you
don't want it to be predominantly
separated and so I think that's what
you're talking about and it reminds me
of when I was I think I was probably
like seventeen or something I went on a
trip to Switzerland with my boyfriend at
the time and we were together for like
five years and he's Swiss or yeah he's
Swiss he I went and he was very very
active and I'm active now but at the
time I wasn't that active and so we
would leave the house for the day and he
would go climb mountains and hang out
with goats and I would go to the most
beautiful picturesque tree and sit
underneath the shade and write in my
journal I in for some people maybe if
they lived there a long time that might
work but it makes for a bit of a wasted
holiday together right apart from the
fact that you're sharing the cost of the
hotel room like you're not really making
the most of the trip right I mean it's
it's okay if you do that like I said in
small amounts but if you really don't
have a way to create that compromise
with each other and you don't have a
general lifestyle that is shared then
it's gonna create a lot of problems a
lot of resentments a lot of power
struggling but again it's all kind of
coming back to that complementarity
between the two people so if when you
complement each other you're not going
to be stuck in a power struggle because
you're gonna basically have a default
mode of decision-making and problem
solving where the man would take the
lead if he's more of the masculine and
dominant role and the woman is more
feminine so when you have that it's
almost like whatever your differences
are should be no big deal
so there are sort of layers where you
start with the real fundamental one when
you're vetting like can you fit together
at least on this basic premise yeah well
and then you escalate
and add all the other layers to see if
you work well together cool so we've got
finding someone that's compatible in
terms of our interests and the way that
we're going to spend time together
then we're talking about sexual polarity
making sure that there's some sexual
chemistry there what's what's next on
the list why would you where would you
look at next to ensure that we have a
hot new relationship the values are so
important you know you got to know the
politics you got to know various things
about morality if you're conservative
your traditional if you're
family-oriented or you're more like an
individualist
a lot of things - like some people just
want it's almost like you're it's kind
of a blend between values and lifestyle
but your vision for the future you have
to have that shared vision for the
future so if you want to have a white
picket fence with six kids
then you better both want that and if
you don't then don't escalate the
relationship yeah if one of you wants to
go traveling around the world exactly so
you have to establish those things and
unless you're you know hooking up on
match.com or something you're not gonna
be filling out some inventory you
actually have to you have to talk to the
person over time and and have
discussions about various topics and and
you don't really want to give them the
sense that you're interrogating them but
you know there may be certain bullet
points that you're looking for but you
do it skillfully and in an appropriate
way that you can at least enjoy the time
it doesn't feel like a job interview I
get you interest me something that's
just come to mind there I was listening
to Jordan Peterson on dr. oz the other
day and yeah first off for anyone who
hasn't listened to it it will be linked
in the show notes below and it is an
epic podcast Jordan I don't know whether
it's that the stress of him being on the
road I know his wife as well Tami's is
really ill at the moment but he breaks
down crying a couple of times on the
episode and I'm like wow I would have
thought they might have cut this or done
something else but they fully leave it
in and he's he's talking empathetically
he's caring about other people and
that's what's causing
to be emotional but he definitely seems
like his emotions have been raised so if
you're listening and you like jbp go and
give it a watch and let me know what you
think I'd love to hear your thoughts it
was it was surprising to mean quite
moving to me as well
and then dr. Oz start swelling up as
well no my god what's going on here one
of the stats that they dropped on there
I totally didn't know this I wonder if
you do apparently living together before
marriage increases the likelihood of
divorce have you seen this statistic
I've heard about it I don't know how I
feel about that is that true in your
experience well I haven't really had a
lot of people that didn't go have the
tape before they married so it's hard
for me to compare but when we talk about
getting to know someone and
compatibility and all those kinds of
things it's it is really important to
have novel experiences together like if
you want to travel you want to injure
some kind of stress so that you can see
how do they handle those crises and and
how do you work together as a team so if
you're not gonna live together then you
better be manufacturing some
opportunities to have that that sort of
context where you have to come together
as a team and manage this situation
that's a really good point it's so I
couldn't believe it when I heard you I
was like what no of course of course you
gotta live together you got like it's
par for the course right you get you
move it together then you get a dog try
the dog out the dogs like a miniature
version of a human and then if the dog
works if the dogs okay that right well
we might try for like a proper one we'll
get will get kid and then you get maybe
another kid linear progression right the
progressive overload of a relationship
but yeah but this that seemed to be
pretty robust and the justification I
think that Jordan and dr. oz had was the
implication for the rest of the
relationship is that I'm going to try
you on before I commit and it apparently
according to them aloud a overarching
narrative of disposability and the fact
that it's gonna be I'm gonna see how you
get on and if this doesn't work then I'm
gonna go somewhere else
I naturally it doesn't that's not how it
seems to me but then I also haven't
looked at the stats so it's an
interesting one I bet you it's measuring
a lot of other things simultaneously
that we're not getting at and and that's
basically the the whole premise of how I
approach working with with people in
order to create healthy and successful
relationships is make sure that you're
not you know with someone who's
basically withholding stuff it's like a
conditional love or commitment a lot of
people in modern times especially in
North America and whatever they're
really trying to look out for themselves
and they aren't committed and if
something goes wrong they are willing to
get a better model or a version of a
lifestyle that maybe will work better
for them rather than doing all the hard
work before and then once you actually
escalate to the point where you're
willing to commit to that person that's
it like you're you've done all of your
homework you've vetted you've compared
your options you've established who you
are and how you're going to manage any
kind of critical sort of juncture that
you would reach with that purpose and
then you know you're gonna come through
it on the other side whereas most people
just sort of jump first and then figure
it out
yeah I wonder how many people that are
listening can see in themselves in
previous relationships that they've
gotten to that they've entered it with
one foot already out of the door just in
case and I know that and it's the same
for me right like it's a it's a
protectionist strategy against being
hurt like opening yourself up and making
yourself vulnerable is a it's a scary
thing to do and by having one foot out
of the door you've always got in the
back of your mind oh well I wasn't that
bothered anyway
and yet well if you continue to roll
that model forward for long enough it's
always not going to work and you're
always going to say oh I just can't find
the right person for me and yeah well
hang in a second if you actually ended
up committing you might have had three
relationships five relationships or one
relationship which was perfect but
because you're there with one foot out
the door like well what chance are you
giving it
and trust I think is one of those
factors that gets sort of misused or
ignored neglected and I find it's really
important to develop that trust from the
from the start very gradually and over
time people rush relationships a lot and
so you know if you start dating whether
it's I don't know if people refer to
dating and and with different
definitions and I did a little poll the
other day on what it was but it seems
like the majority of people agree that
dating means one person exclusively but
there are about thirty percent for the
people that I polled was like a thousand
people said thirty percent said it's
multiple people sixty percent said it's
one person so we do need to make sure
we're using the same definition but
that's sixty percent are really angry at
the thirty percent and that's exactly
where this no-man's land
so we said it before in the UK I don't
know this the same in the u.s. it's
called seeing someone so seeing someone
is after casual sex but before an
official relationship so it's whatever
that that bit in the middle is and it no
one knows what the [ __ ] that means I
don't know what it means we spent we
spent four episodes trying to work out
what the [ __ ] it means and we have no
idea at all it's just this no-man's land
of you not why you're not committed if
you if you just having sex with that one
person but you maybe you're not ready
for a relationship I to me it's like
it's hedging your bets in in the worst
way possible like Egypt but you're not
gaining you've got all of the loss you
don't have the security of knowing that
that person really cares about you you
don't have the ability to fully commit
emotionally you've got sex on top but
you could have had that anyway and yeah
I just think it's a dangerous dangerous
waters to swim in if you're seeing
someone and you're listening
beware the Sharks in those waters okay
so just watch out and I encourage women
when when it doesn't mean that there's
multiple people involved from the man's
side but maybe there's ambiguity they're
not sure what quite they're dealing with
but their values are to be exclusive to
be monogamous I I encourage women to
stick to that as long as you're you're
vetting
the man and you're feeling like you
still you're still curious you're still
interested you still want to two more
time with them give trust give
exclusivity do not hedge your bets
because that is sabotaging the
relationship no matter how you look at
it it's always gonna sabotage the
relationship yeah so men and women are a
little bit different I think they have a
little bit more leeway the men to sort
of hedge their bets I guess but I don't
think that it's the best solution for
long you know in the long term I think
that if you keep that to a very short
period just to make sure the basic
foundation exists between the two people
like you make your choice and then you
go into an exclusive sexual relationship
with that person but a lot of times
people are holding back trust or holding
back the attachment or emotion until
they know for sure as if there's some
kind of destination that they're trying
to must be you must be this right this
tall to ride the roller coaster you must
have been together for this long for me
to be exclusive with you and the worst
thing is that if you've had that basis
if you've created the relationship on
the basis of you sleeping with other
people like what if it comes out at some
point like what if you get rumbled that
and it's happened like lots of the guys
that I work with have had this situation
where they've done something towards the
beginning of a relationship and six
months one year in their girlfriends
found out and it's like what you didn't
tell me said well we weren't going out
that situation you didn't tell me but we
weren't going out is never ever going to
be reconciled ever in the history of
ever like it's just always gonna get
brought what else are you keeping from
me one person is gonna say well I didn't
need to tell you because it wasn't time
we weren't exclusive
near the person's gonna say well I don't
trust you [ __ ] fully [ __ ] yeah and I'm
trying to hammer this this point home a
lot lately anyway yeah I think it's so
important to to stand by it's really the
easiest way to exist you know do not
have anything to hide
to be direct to be clear to be
straightforward from the beginning even
when it comes to even though I
exclusivity even if we're talking about
non-exclusivity just be ethical about it
be upfront it's you're still vetting
your partner it's the same process it's
just you're looking for someone who is
comfortable and values non-exclusivity
and so the two of you can go about your
business doing whatever it is that works
for you and and be open about it until
you decide I want to be exclusive with
you if that's where they're going which
which developmentally you know you're
talking about sort of pressure and in
Hollywood and media to have like this
love story I do believe that naturally
the progression of Inhumans is to be
together I don't think it's about being
a singular individual for your entire
lifespan but it's not you're not
incomplete as an individual you're in
process and there's comes a point in
time where you kind of reach a plateau
of who you are you know even though you
can kind of have novel experiences and
kind of tweak this let's week bad and
always be striving to eat better and
sleep and do all the exercises and all
of that stuff you do kind of end up
plateauing and it isn't until you know
you you find that attracts that really
great partner that challenges you and
draws like good and bad and complexity
out of you and then you develop a family
and and start to bring forward that that
legacy that you really get to that
different type of love of service and
commitment and loyalty and and all that
that's a really good point I can
certainly see myself so I'm 31 and I'm
single and I can certainly see myself
what you're talking about there that you
can continue to have your adventures in
life and kind of keep yourself
interested I've just come back from
America I did a four-week road trip with
one of my good mates in a 5-liter
soft-top Camaro going across America
like oh wow oh cool way to do it yeah
but you're right it is that is a
different flavor of all of the other
adventures that I've had so far
it's still I'm still on whatever level
this level is level one or level 10 or
level 100 but to get to level 101 the
challenge that you have from somebody
else how do we start a family how do I
negotiate a serious relationship with
someone that's going to be something
that goes on for a long time I think
that's a really really good point so I
wanted to I wait to get on to a trust
we've touched on it a little bit so far
in your experience what is the ability
of people to come back from trust being
broken in a relationship how does that
work
it's extremely difficult I mean it
depends on the injury
what if it's infidelity then gosh I was
having actually a little debate with
Android Tate today which is always fun
but he was saying that he actually said
it made a comments about all the
relationship experts out there go go
cheat on your woman and see what she
does if she's if she leaves you she
never loved you you do not give a [ __ ]
my friend well we had a really you
should read the thread it's really good
the show notes below yeah definitely
but we kind of came to a good sort of
compromise and we were talking about men
being kings and how in the history of
existence all the kings had although
women they wanted well not not all men
are meant to be kings and that's okay
and women not all women want to be with
Kings Yeah right because if we have our
certain values so if a woman has a lot
of ego or pride or whatever she may want
that King of Kings but what what I don't
even I mean I guess I'm a regular woman
but I think I'm pretty cool what I'm
looking for is is a man that I can
develop my own sort of Empire with it's
not an actual Kingdom that's gonna be
ruling people I want my man to be my
king and that is what matters to me I
don't want to be worried about
infidelity and having to share things
like that's not my value so that's why
I'm about exclusive
and monogamy and creating a family that
has honor and integrity and Trust and
all of that so people have choice so
it's not just we're not just ruled by
our biology we have you no morals we
have you know all the sort of
socio-cultural implications that
influence our behavior so to just say
and rationalize all of this hedonism
based on biology is just you know it's
kind of an excuse it really is there's a
lot of moving parts here isn't it so the
Caleb Jones episode a lot of people that
are listening will have heard that and
it was super interesting if you haven't
heard that employee to go back and
listen it it's a challenging thing to
listen to to hear the argument for
non-monogamy it was it was challenging
for me right like to think okay so I
love this person but in some of the
version of the world I'm gonna give this
non-monogamy stuff a crack I'm gonna try
but I have to let someone that I love
sleep with whoever she wants and I'm
like it immediately it just gives this
juvenile visceral response and I'm like
I I'm only trying to do this
rhetorically and I haven't got past the
first [ __ ] hurdle so how people do it
in the real world is beyond me also some
of the listeners may be thinking I
wonder what happened to Aubree Marcus
you mentioned him a couple of times on
the Caleb Jones episode well let me tell
you unfortunately Aubrey and his wife
Whitney announced that they were
transitioning their relationship on
Instagram the other day but in case
you're interested they did a full
podcast about it which shows everything
that I mentioned on the Caleb Jones
episode about why I thought that
relationship was doomed and that's a
that's a callback to a couple of other
points but here's a point for you here's
a piece of relationship advice I'm sure
that you can get on board with dr.
burrows if you are breaking up with
someone do not do a podcast about it
with them
that's [ __ ] everything everything in
obras life at the moment is like just
used as content it's so it's it's
madness but yes I think the thing about
the Kings thing there's two types of
Kings rather there's multiple types
there's a tyrant and then there's the
noble virtuous king like both of them
of the title but the two very different
people and I think that you've
identified a you have one person who
uses their power to get whatever they
want and you have one person who uses
their power to raise everybody else up
and again we're talking compatibility
and stuff like that you mentioned that
infidelity in a relationship is a
difficult point to come back from yeah
so you might not know where you stand on
that until it happens right and that can
always be very difficult so you might
have a person who just wants to put
their head in the sand and and not
really deal with it just deny it pretend
like they don't know and go about their
business it's just easier for them to
that's basically their coop their
psychological coping skill is denial and
so that might be one way for they for
them to cope with it and so they're okay
sort of dealing with it they don't have
we don't have too much of an issue in
counseling or coaching to heal the
relationship on that issue but I promise
you that's gonna bleed into other areas
of their relationship that needs some
work so I would want to look at at other
things as well and if they're willing to
but not everybody is willing to fix the
things that the inconsistencies that
sort of lay at the foundation that make
other problems surface now you also
might have the woman that like freaks
out and throws things and yells and
talks to everyone about what a piece of
crap you are and you know sort of
punishes you and and then that woman may
be just very angry and she never really
comes out of the angry anger phase and
so working with her I have to get her to
look at taking responsibility and not
only responsibility but some piece of it
in order for them to find common ground
to both make changes to heal the
relationship and that's very very hard
for a person who feels that they were
the one that was injured they were the
one that's betrayed how am I supposed to
say I need to do this differently
because it wasn't my fault
but if you do get through that anger
stage and that takes some time then you
look at well what led to this infidelity
you know what what was the wedge that
broke you guys apart that maybe constant
was what was the sex life between the
two of you like before what was the
communication like what was the general
intimacy so you know you have to peel
back the layers but then I said this to
you before in the beginning if one
person is willing to change and the
other person is not for whatever reason
whatever soap box they're standing on
pointing a finger at the other person
saying they're the one that needs to
change it's not going to work do you
find that these people who are I'm going
to use Carol Dweck's words here in a
fixed mindset and a growth mindset do
people tend to stay like that throughout
relationships well if we're comparing it
to that type of scenario yeah it's very
hard for someone who's in a fixed
mindset to basically evolve I like to
call it the power struggle and so a lot
of times you'll see that from whether I
mean it can be the man to but you do see
it a lot with women who feel that
they're entitled and that the man should
be doting on making them happy and
everything's offensive to that woman and
she feels like she should have just as
much rights and control and wear the
pants and everything's equal that is a
very fixed mindset that does not really
budge until something major happens some
kind of rock bottom's
yeah yeah but for me for men I don't
know what you think might be the most
fixed element of a fixed mindset in a
man but I mean if we're talking about
the complement to that a lot of times
it's it's the men who are more emotional
eyes danda feminized they they're so
indoctrinated into that mindset of being
the sort of male feminist and trying to
rescue women and play that role but
there's lots of different fixed mindsets
so it's not just that stereotype but it
can happen people can be develop a
growth mindset after some kind of
catalysts yeah I wouldn't
I'd love to be able to see where the
fixing growth mindset comes you know it
typically a broad cross-section of
relationships because I'm sure the
listeners at home will be able to think
the same I can come up with just as many
people that are absolutely stuck in the
mud as men as our women I think it's a
an affliction that plagues both genders
equally but it manifests in different
ways right you I think you're right like
the girl that's got the fixed mindset
perhaps might yeah they might have their
I want to click my fingers I want to be
in control the man might be the one that
you should you should be attracted to me
or love me the way that that like
whatever I do no matter how I behave and
and tend to sort of push the boundaries
a little bit more so yeah you are right
there's a lot of nuances here I mean
just going through what we've gone
through so far today 14 years of
clinical mental health and family
experience I can only imagine what it's
like getting home from work after that
day after hearing whatever you know six
eight ten hours of this this animated by
two people that I mean do many people
come to marriage counseling when they
got stuff going right I'm gonna guess
not no but I did have some people that
after things got resolved they would
come it's kind of like a check-in
preventative semi-annual session which I
encouraged and now it sort of leads into
my working with people at the very front
end of things but yeah I mean I feared
off that track for a reason because it
was just so disease model oriented and
so now you know working online with
people and not being in that setting is
much better because my quality of life
is a lot better and it's definitely more
aligned with my values as well are you
slowly regaining some sanity after the
last decade a bit yeah you know I feel
like I've definitely grown a lot as a
person and applying this into my
personal life has been really conducive
to success and and feeling like I'm in a
healthy place and I'm you know I'm
dating and I
I'm feeling like very optimistic and
that these things are very helpful for
people to implement and a lot of my
clients are having results and they're
seeing you know much much better
outcomes in their relationship so it's
great to hear that feedback now that's
awesome
so we've touched on compatibility
between people in terms of their
routines we've talked about sexual
polarity and ensuring that you have some
some sort of polarity some sort of
energy which is drawing people together
we've spoken about values and virtues
like what's your life plan are you white
picket fence are you adventures in
Himalaya typing we spoke about
infidelity and Trust and the issues with
that as well
are there any other sort of key themes
that you think that the listeners should
be aware of well if we have to kind of
talk directly about sex for a minute
let's talk let's talk directly about sex
ruin it it's really important for women
especially men I mean we work together
but men kind of you know they're
comfortable talking about sex there
comfortable having lots of sex but women
feel somewhat restrained in their
sexuality and I've been trying to to
discuss this a lot to separate this sort
of negative [ __ ] explicit sexuality
from the very sensual healthy feminine
sensuality whether you call it sexy or
or a sensual doesn't really matter but
just sort of distinguishing the two
between that sort of corrupt objectified
version that's sort of blatant
and inappropriate so women have been
sort of inundated with this image and
even with men they kind of do the same
thing they split their images of women
into you know the virtuous with a
Madonna and the and the sort of [ __ ]
right like that sort of having the the
[ __ ] and then that the pure version of
a woman and basically women have been
doing that in a way that they they
choose one or the other
they're not really integrating both
archetypes I mean there's more than just
the two but if we just look at those two
women are sort of rejecting the explicit
sexual element and trying to be very
demure or the opposite and so trying to
integrate those two is a very difficult
process for women because there's so
much stigma attached to it and we talk
about
promiscuity and sexual liberation and
nobody really knows what to do and and
then women are judged if they've had too
many sexual partners or if they're too
seductive or their dresses you know to
you know it's like exposing of
themselves so learning for women how how
to be selective with their sexual
partners and yet be very open and free
with their sexual partners is a very
hard process and I think it's important
to address whether I work with women
one-on-one or I work with couples for if
you have that trust in a relationship
right then you're gonna have a much
better time exploring that that you know
that complexity because you should feel
that your woman is you know honorable
and she's committed to you and you don't
have to worry about her doing anything
inappropriate in a sexualized way with
somebody else but with you she should be
more open and adventurous and be able to
be comfortable in her body and basically
explicit so you have you have to really
accommodate that growth and be growth to
have that growth mindset there you know
isn't it strange that when we're talking
about the female sexual archetypes that
being capable in bed is also lumbered
with the same label of being promiscuous
or being a [ __ ] or whatever the term is
not weird yeah it's it's something that
we don't really feel comfortable talking
about and so I mean I'm not I'm not like
advocating for us to talk about sex with
children but I think it is important for
women to be able to talk about it with
their partners if they're feeling shy or
if they're feeling uncomfortable or
unsure about
and why and for the man to be able to
have that intimacy with her to make her
feel comfortable to make her feel that
it's okay and you know you have to be
prepared because then you have to sort
of still see her as a mother if you have
children but then she's your hot sexy
lover behind closed doors or whatever
role that women have got to play haven't
they like the man kind of if we've got
again typical masculine feminine
energies going from the ways that they
mostly do
you've got the mat and the man's kind of
always doing that right like he's fixing
the car picking the kids up off the
ground he's going to work and then he's
coming home and he's having sex whereas
the mother needs to be a lot of a lot of
different roles right I think that
that's maybe one of the issues where
you've got that they they need to spin a
lot of plates and if they're not and
they're repressing that that's what
happens to in the demise of a
relationship is she will do that she'll
sort of see her husband as the protector
provider and then she'll start
fantasizing about the sexy gardener or
whatever right so if you don't address
these issues early on starting from when
you're dating then they're gonna create
these cracks in your relationship that
are going to create like the sort of
risk for all those types of outcomes and
being able to I it's almost like you
have to have that rhythm and harmony and
be in sync with your partner so that you
can kind of be really hyper like sexual
with them but then also talk about day
to day logistics and the boring stuff
yeah but we've run out of we've run out
of milk and we've run out of bread it's
your turn to clean the toilet like yeah
and come over here some of that you know
like it shouldn't be and and and it's
it's it's fun it's playful and that's
what keeps the spark alive and so you
don't want to drag on all of that sort
of boring life stuff for too long
without injecting a little bit of that
pizazz and that sexiness in there so you
know women
we need to feel encouraged to do that
and men have to learn how to sort of
draw that out of us as well because it's
there it's just a matter of feeling that
comfort and in that trust in order to do
that how do you do that then as a man
encouraging a woman or as a woman
wanting to broach this subject of sex or
sexual preferences or the way that their
sex life is going how do you do that how
do you get the courage to do that and
how do you start the discussion well a
man should feel confident in his
sexuality I do feel that it's important
for a man to have a little bit more he
you know neither party has to have a
whole bunch of experience but I do think
that it's good for the man to be a
little bit more sexually confident than
the woman so to keep that balance and
then for him to be able to project that
throughout the relationship so that he's
kind of it doesn't matter if he sort of
comes out of nowhere with something
sexualized and that maybe startles her a
little bit or she feels a little shy or
something but that's gonna create that
sexual tension that that's going to
really help there in that department and
so the man if he doesn't feel confident
in that element with his sexuality he
needs to work on that so that would mean
that he needs to do that individual work
first like go to the gym get your
fitness right get your health checked
make sure toss testosterone levels are
healthy and you're eating well you're
sleeping well and you know once you get
all those things it should it should be
revved up and if you you're also sort of
encouraging your your woman to be
attractive and feminine and whatever it
is and hopefully you've already sort of
established what you like and she's that
something completely different doomed to
fail if that way yeah exactly so you
know the best thing to do is not to
criticize a woman directly and I was
actually gonna say this before one of
the differences between the fixed
mindset between the genders is women do
not handle criticism well in general men
can handle criticism a lot what a lot
better I have like 80 something percent
men clients and not not very many
women because of that it's it's really
interesting to see but you know we need
to get the women to be a little bit more
open to criticism and self-improvement
for sure but anyway getting back to the
sex stuff so yeah with men as long as
they're improving that those elements
making sure that they have what they
need in order to be better and then they
can encourage their woman always instead
of instead of criticizing her encourage
her positively so reward and reinforce
the positives like if she wears
something and you think she's really hot
like give her that attention attention
is like that that really powerful
currency with women so be seductive with
her buy her flowers take her out say
lovely things whatever her love
languages and her personality dictates
you want to to reinforce those positives
and then on the flip side if you do see
negatives instead of directly
criticizing her pull back right so
you're pulling back on the attention
instead of punishing you're just taking
away the rewards and use external
references to point out the negatives so
like if you see a woman wearing
something really ugly or her hair's
shorts and unattractive or whatever it
is say oh gosh I wish she had much
longer hair she would just be so sexy if
she would do this that's a way to
externalize it from the woman and the
woman's like competing and saying oh
well I did that I better get a nice
dress then okay that's an interesting
approach of using this conduit on the
outside to somehow come into it so it's
spoken about what men can do how about
if you're a woman you could be demure
you could be totally sexually liberated
but you need to broach the subject of
sex with your partner where do you where
do you start I think you just talk about
it one thing that came to mind though
that when you asked that I have a very
split opinion on masturbation because I
know this whole nofap thing is like a
really popular controversial topic get
me started
[Laughter]
well this is my thing okay
yeah I I'm not against masturbation but
definitely one of the things that I
think is this thing this is this is
distinct between men and women is that
masturbation can be extremely helpful
for women who have repressed sexuality
why because you have to kind of scaffold
her level of comfort when it comes to
any type of sexualized material like
even if it's just her like it's almost
like learning how to act on on stage
like how to be a public speaker being
exposed and that vulnerable in a sexual
way can be so anxiety provoking for
women that she's got to desensitize
herself in a good way not in a bad way
so she can get used to it
so learning how to masturbate or what
does she like or even you know getting a
little bit you know freaky with herself
you know like that will help like get
her used to the idea and then and then
if she kind of gets into it a little bit
more when she's actually in the act with
her lover and then the lover reinforces
it and he's like Holly yeah you know
he's sort of like encouraging that then
she can loosen up a little bit more
during the act let her guard down
climax easier and then you talk about it
afterwards like oh my gosh that was
really cool when he did that I just
thought it was so sexy and you know it
just sort of gets your little you know
endorphins and your oxytocin is like all
on fire and yeah anyway there's going
low now you'll be fine oh your battery
on your phone you mean though right yeah
yeah so I think I think that's
interesting like the fact that not women
are under sexualized I think is what you
on the whole they're less sexualized
than men I think is the point you're
making
right one thing that I think super
interesting that I'd be interested to
you what you think about is like Cosmo
magazine and all of these sort of
middle-of-the-road girlie magazines
every single one of those that I see
when I walk past WH Smiths or some news
agents like the seven best summer sex
positions and things like that is that
is that female journalists and magazine
writers trying to sort of take control
of this and help women to educate
themselves because that's been going on
for like as long as I can remember
seeing those magazines like twenty years
thirty years more and that has that
really helped is that not the right
rhetoric no and as soon as I said
answered your question I was like well
the caveat is there's this whole other
sort of sexual liberation liberated
feminism thing that has taken effect and
so you have the hyper sexual women that
are super promiscuous and explicit but
then you know what it's not a healthy
sexuality either and it's not real it's
actually like a fake facade of sexuality
because they're doing it in a
disconnected way they're playing a part
that isn't even it isn't even something
that is representative of intimacy right
it's just some sort of caricature of
this explicitness so right a lot of that
cosmopolitan and I forget what there was
a headline yesterday or maybe it was
this morning talking about women I don't
know women doing this or that sexual
behavior and promoting it and I think
it's just one it's causing us to then
become more promiscuous as women and
having more casual casual sex is really
going to infringe our ability to find a
proper partner to attach properly to a
romantic partner long term and it also
just desensitizes us to our own body and
emotionally basically if you as I'm also
like a sexual trauma recovery specialist
and part of sexual trauma
is this what happens is this this
disorientation and detachment between
the body and your emotions and then you
sort of have this self-imposed
objectification like right like and then
itself exactly and so I call it self
exploitation but basically it's
literally just you you're separating
disconnecting from your body so that you
can like kind of use your body and
objectify it however you like but
emotionally you feel really guilty and
shameful about it and so it's disjointed
and and it's dysfunctional and so why
are we even trying to do that
voluntarily you know what happens to a
sexual trauma victim is not something we
should be trying to replicate
voluntarily to ourselves and so healing
a woman's relationship to her body to
her sexuality is really my goal of
helping women do that and so learning
how to be sexual with your partner is
the key and so as long as you have that
healthy context then yeah you don't have
to disconnect because you're attached to
that person you trust that person you
love that person it's not someone that's
random or you know just used for a
thrill that's a very superficial bodily
response and to have that distinct from
an emotional attachment is unhealthy I
couldn't agree more I think that's a
really lovely note to finish it on so
dr. burrows people that have listened
they might want to get in touch or find
out a little bit more about you where
can they go my website is a great place
to go though I need to upgrade that a
little bit it's dr. burrows
dr. Taylor burrows comm sorry and that
Twitter is a great place as well so at
Taylor burrows fantastic well all of
this will be linked in the show notes
below if you want to go and check out
dr. burrows running with mr. Tate make
sure that's linked in the show notes
below but thank you so much for your
time I think we'll have really helped
some people today I hope so but let me
know I'll like to follow up if there is
more to add
thank you
[Music]
you